welcome everybody today sri podcast
episode number 50 Wow
halfway to 100 I don't know that most
podcasts would celebrate 50 but it's
been a lot of ups and downs a lot of
bumps a lot of strikes and gutters here
so I think the fact that we made 50 is
worth a golf club I think so and in life
take any chance to celebrate I think
that's a good policy I think that's
encouraging it's a beautiful thing
give yourself small milestones any
chance to celebrate put that on my
tombstone I saw that's just like what I
do is like if I managed to walk a little
bit extra in a day I'm like let's
celebrate with a pizza and that's how
you end up looking like ya - on Thursday
at 7 p.m. we have rhett and Link coming
to the studio leave your question on the
subreddit for them today we have a very
special top of the month with my good
wonderful hilarious friend Zac Adel aka
psychic pebbles on the sound board and
on the mic we call him mr. hilarious
because he's just so funny
Zac tip the beanie what is up freak
[ __ ] that's my catchphrase get used
to it
that's it that's what Joe Rogan says
isn't it everybody let Joe Rogan know
that Zac's coming for him boy you're up
buddy
zach is known for being litigious so I'd
be careful 70 lawsuits of the one
uh-hum today's episode is sponsored by
the one and only teddy fresh mrs. teddy
fresh what are you wearing Ella I am
wearing the collar black windbreaker
just came out today and I am wearing the
revenge of the Ted sweater
oh sorry headphones feels so good this
is like what a great sweater um guys go
to Teddy fresh calm we have set up a
special offer just for our podcast
listeners tan why are you manhandling my
dog like a bag of groceries you just
punted it hand Watson Leigh is holding
the dog is like
[Laughter]
just for our podcast listeners use code
h3 a check out for free shipping in the
US
free shipping oh my god
what are we Amazon mm-hmm this week we
are so if you are in the market for this
amazing sweater or windbreaker head on
over to teddy fresh calm and use the
code age 3 by that murders by that merch
I get it now
and of course I don't get the
opportunity to thank you all enough but
all you wonderful beautiful twitch prime
subscribers and just straight up
subscribers on Twitch oh my god thank
you guys so much for clicking smashing
that button for us because if your dick
was in front of me right now ela mine
not your I mean if your your David yes
if you hit that stop button it's
basically like if you I had a dick I
work it are this weird so thanks for
smashing that button now let's get right
back in let's just get right into this
gals a really long intro if you guys
haven't seen the jacksFilms parody of
led that's what we were fairings going
right great video that was a really
terrific video let's get right back
let's let's get right into it all right
here's the deal of top store we've got a
lot to cover here Logan Paul I haven't
had a chance to talk about the whole
fiasco surrounding Logan Paul's channel
being demonetized
for tasering a dead rat now we don't
have to talk there's a pattern of
behavior here with Logan Paul of playing
with dead dead corpses in adamant once
living things he has sociopathic
behavior it's pretty weird like you
would think that it would be
overthinking every little thing he's
doing right now because everyone is
looking he would be a little sensitive
to tasing dead rats or taking living
fish out of his koi pond and performing
CPR on them as they breathe at they
desperately
gasps freer but nope well this is thing
about Logan is that before the suicide
force thing this is who he was he was a
he was this guy he was desecrating
corpses long before the suicide forest
and YouTube was stroking his [ __ ] like
as you know as if somebody bought his
March or subscribed on Twitch like
that's what I don't like about how you
like before all this they were giving
him YouTube read movies they were giving
him YouTube red shows he was like the
face of YouTube rewind I think YouTube
is getting walk right now
wake the flip up and get go because they
thought of lager is just it's like the
safest content and they probably didn't
even then even more notorious videos
exact figured it's a vlog what could go
exactly a bunch of kids it's just Logan
Paul whatever but this guy yeah they
didn't bother to check out like who is
this guy so they've got the time and
effort the people at face value like
filthy Frank and items and us they're
like keep them in arms like I don't have
anything with them but Logan Paul is
running around desecrating corpses and
they make him the face of YouTube but
sick it's it's so twisted bro and now
all the sudden it's like oh we know
Logan who we never heard of him it's
like no you made him famous you prop
this psychopath up by that merch well
anyway I know it's song he's singing
now that is channel ste monetized you
know so it's a really quick you know we
were talking about before but I don't
think the dead rat part look if a lot of
jackass could have done that people you
met you before filthy frankenz don't
stuff with the animals I think the big
difference here though is that not that
he did that stuff cuz that in the vacuum
is not don't worst thing to do morally
right but the difference is everybody
was looking at him and he got he thought
he could out charm you know doing that
right after the whole corpse Fiasco in
Japan that's the big thing to me it's
not that he I mean the act is bad but
it's not the bigger thing if it is it's
the context of it right it's not that
bad at the fact
you but we doing that right after when
you know everybody's looking at you is
pretty [ __ ] it's pretty nutty to me I
I saw a lot of of people being it's
really the context of how it happened
right there matters well it's just like
will you will you be a little bit weary
of doing anything bad if you just
[ __ ] the show to rigor mortis corpse
behind you I'm feeling loaded
I mean seriously was a decomposing man
and they went you know what I think I
think I think my comeback needs a
beautiful CPR a [ __ ] living koi I
mean ripped out of its pods people were
comparing it to like well we're all
celebrating Logan's channel being
demonetised
but we would have filthy Frank was doing
this a year plus ago and nobody and like
obviously we would be a grief that
happened to him but Tim today so those
people I say it's a different time I
mean we all except now this is not the
YouTube it used to be yeah this is post
this is post that pocalypse world this
is like 911 on YouTube like the rules
are just different
you can't send anthrax to two people in
the mail anymore like he always mailed
his P that's a perfect Joey South was
mailing urine to people that's the kind
of wild-west 9/11 okay we take our shoes
off at checkpoints this is just the new
reality now okay and Lobo Paul not only
knew that he was at the center of it
right and he made this whole Cheney's
cheesy corny PR I'm donating a million
bucks to suicide prevention by the way
worst the receipt on that I'm not
doubting you I'm just saying wait
where's Jordan I want to hear what
Jordan has to say Jordan's a local pawn
fan yeah I'd like to see him to defend
this well he said he was defibrillating
the but like it's a it's a different era
and Logan Paul was at the center of this
I mean he was under a microscope yeah
this is him on good behavior he this is
him on good behavior
yeah I don't have time to go back and
watch all of his videos but he was
probably torturing animals for long
before his parents know he was torturing
animals from a young age and they let
him out into the world
really
anyway let's let's let's take a closer
look
the thing about Logan that really
grinded my gears was he came back after
this break
he made this wonderful PR video about
suicide and stuff but he during that
time he showed absolutely no remorse and
basically spit in the face of YouTube
and and everyone who was criticizing him
with certain things for example let me
show you the first one he went after the
controversy I mean a weeks after it
cardi B posted on Instagram this picture
and she said they're trying to crucify
me like they did Christ okay now what do
you think Logan said in response to that
I think he said that's a bit of an
exaggeration he says give me a break
you'll come on no he says lols you
telling me so in in Logan's mind in the
midst of getting [ __ ] he's being
crucified like Jesus he's dying at the
cross he's the martyr he did nothing
wrong this evil world is the one that
put him up friend for the injustice I
mean this is this is dilution on on the
highest scale and beyond that he's
writing it on cardi B's Instagram like
she's gonna notice it be like oh my god
Logan Paul commented yeah that's not all
folks folks and the facts next up Logan
Paul here
here's his comeback video after the
suicide the suicide meme where you
supposedly by the way if you're gonna
donate a million dollars a guy like
Logan Paul who's all about being flashy
and show off he you think he'd have like
a giant check or something or receiving
be like hey guys here's the I'm not
saying he's a liar but all I'm saying is
where's the proof no no no I think he
claimed but I'm just saying are we
supposed to take this guy
face value that's an incredible claim I
donate a million dollars to suicide
prevention where's that Chad I think
it's worth the waffle to ask for proof
for that I think it's a pretty
reasonable claim I would provide it
because this is the internet everybody's
skeptical I think it's just a missed
opportunity of using one of those big
checks and I mean that's a principle of
life when you get a chance to use a big
check of Caesar for Christ's sake I mean
I I gotta be honest I watch that part so
I don't know what's the what proof did
he provide well no he just said he says
at the end of video I'm from I'm
donating a million dollars to suicide
prevention mm-hmm and then everybody was
like oh my god well if you do do it good
job
yeah yeah but did he receive where that
receipt we're not receipt no but
seriously where that receipt you know
everybody at Logan Paul where that
receipt everybody not please don't it's
too late it's too like that so I mean
just put that on there don't do that
don't don't
whatever you do don't tweet at Logan
Paul where that receipts that would be a
really immature thing to do don't do it
let's go up we're better than that but
if I was a judge and this was hereditary
I would say just show me there was this
was Judge Judy she would say to him
Logan Paul versus the court of public
opinion Judge Judy would say Logan let
me see the receipts yeah Julianne
executional you would say provide me
some receipts if you were judge dredd if
I could say a big claim that he wouldn't
even try to fake it I'm pretty sure he
did it I don't see I know there's a
chance he there but I don't think so
you're saying there's a chance
all right let's move on but but
seriously where the receipt hashtag
let's get that treasure so anyway here
so after the whole where's the receipt
scandal the non-existent scandal so this
was his his comeback Logan powers back
there's a lot of conceit a lot of
arrogance a lot of self congratulatory
dick is broken where chaos hides in the
shadows
dictated by pure and absolute savagery
one absolutely one boy
I noticed he always does this where he's
like I'm not a man I'm a boy I'm a boy
from Ohio I'm just yeah you I can't be
held responsible for anything I'm a 22
year old boy you're a [ __ ] fully
grown man they have a lot of
responsibility you're not a boy why like
you have this whole ego thing and you
prefer to be called a boy I think I
think it's to say that I'm so young yeah
they're so so successful I think that's
the point of it it's only 22 of them
humblebrag
I guess you're right everything
everything seems to be carefully
manicured manicured to stroke his gentle
you go not gentle but really not gentle
actually questioning something I've been
questioning his age for a long time just
like he's 62
where's the [ __ ] where's the
emergency serious what the log sir I
love that I love it the birth
certificates not enough money
legend
no I'm Logan
Jake is my brother I'm looking for oh
snap
okay okay a little bit of a goof how
would you rate that mr. hilarious yeah
is there a fart or [ __ ] sound effect on
this thing dad is there an ass farting
really create an ass for new [ __ ] so
defect on this so I can write that yeah
that rap for you the idea that that mr.
Hill attack mr. hilarious will be a
continuous presence here on the sound
board on commentary so we got to make
sure he gets everything he needs den
yeah I need to be alright so anyway so
you rate that a fart noise yeah you know
there's something really christ-like
about that video like he's got this long
beard he's gets like it's like Christ
died he's kind of rising from the dead
he literally commented that on cardi B I
think that's attention I think it's very
a christ-like symbolism so it's coming
to a it's coming to a head here soon the
Maverick Logan Paul
showing his face for the first time
after the disgraced youtuber has been
spotted
[Music]
he's like did you guys notice my apology
had 50 million views and paparazzi were
taking my pictures all the time like I'm
not gonna say that yeah I messed up but
did you see how much publicity I got out
of it did you see that I managed to fake
cry Hollywood what did they say
you look sincere but it it gonna have
the feeling that you're just a good at
what what's that saying I don't know
what you're referring to you know what
I'm not gonna try it out this is your
own hour can take a three week break hey
a million so yeah so he put the humility
thing to this at the side really quick
who else can get a million subscribers
and I didn't get I'm not disgraced I
took a break I just wanted a little
break after my vacation to Japan wasn't
really related to anything I just wanted
to relax a little bit because I work
really hard not related to the
desecration of corpses by the way is
there any corpses around because I'm
gonna do you mind if I rub my dick on
some dead creatures [ __ ] that koi it's
disgusting
deep fake this is the vibe like I'm
following all this and I'm I'm upset
because I'm like this guy doesn't give a
crap
he doesn't care and he's just this kind
of behavior of just he's like deflecting
all the blame I he's been crucified like
Jesus and his mind and it's just he spit
he the PR thing was just so transparent
at this point and he's just such a
[ __ ] here look at this from Twitter
the evidence mounts still come on guys
we got this there was a petition to
delete his channel which is obviously a
lot of people venting their frustration
about how messed up the thing is
it had over a half a million sub sub my
signature signature now here he is uh
you know essentially saying that I think
they're all handicapped
well he's acting like he's got a little
you know his eyes are a little goofy he
thinks they're [ __ ] he thinks there
was no I think that he can like make fun
of it and he's like [ __ ] that's what
he's saying am I wrong in saying that he
was calling people yeah I don't see that
but I do see that he's trying to make it
seem like you can just joke about it you
know what I mean
come on guys we got this but essentially
not taking anything seriously deflecting
all the blame and being a little bit of
a [ __ ] and not really changing so
there's this mounting evidence Exhibit C
and then we've got more in case you
needed more reasons to hate Logan Paul
he made a video this one really tickles
my berries
unbeliev that's an expression he made a
video where he dresses up and asks
college students what they think about
Logan Paul do you guys notice anything
weird about the background he used the
thumbnail that picture of his face when
he's right in front of the corpse he
used that to clickbait his new video in
the background click baiting himself
let's make John suicide forest video
thumbnail the he chose after all this
[ __ ] it's completely my finding
absolutely mind-bending and there's more
still my god here we go let's open this
up so he's asking these guys do you know
Logan pause a lot of them are like no I
don't you can tell he's like pretty
messed up right pretty insensitive right
from what we see like that was not a
good I don't personally that's a fact an
actual factual verifiable thing I mean I
didn't watch the whole thing but I know
like a lot of other like influencers
were talking about it yeah I was just
respectful but the same time intention
really it was taken way out of
proportion so you don't think we should
throw him off a building no of course
not that's like totally hypocritical but
Penny's about that Logan :
we found someone who supports me I love
this one okay respect speaking of people
that people don't like how about that
Logan Paul character no you need that
suicide forest video pretty messed up
right pretty insensitive right I don't
know dude I just like the Logan's like
luckily I do usually get pretty
insensitive he was behind for the corpse
[Laughter]
and then it's like way are you Logan
Paul this is stranger you should be the
thing that's weird is you should be
distancing yourself it's time to move
past this and he's trying he's trying
he's not like trying to me me he's
trying to capitalize on it and clickbait
himself in the tongue this video has 10
million views he clicked baited himself
in the thumbnail in front of the corpse
and he's like capitalizing on it it's
just bizarre man so here guys let's
watch the logan paul taste some dead
rats
[Applause]
you can see how disturbed his problem
not something like a bad idea coming off
of the writers and at the very least
edited out and post like do it on the
spot you're a little crazy you're a
little wild embracing being like the bad
boy anything so you can make it cool you
know the 50s guys would have like
leather jackets and motorcycles so this
is the bad boy now you got a Taser dead
rat screaming the microphone the neuera
bad boy
the memories oh he's so dreamy he chases
rats
you can see how disturbed his friends
are actually have to be yes man they
can't push back too much or they get
banished well they know they'll be the
red suit if they say no have you not
desecrated enough corpses I mean there's
something to be said the guy knows his
audience is young okay but he's not
really accountable for who watches his
stuff it's more of the fact that he's in
a new age that he helped ushered in and
he was just in trouble for desecrating a
corpse that's that's toned down that
corpse desecration for at least a month
I'm just shocked that he thought he
could like Jarvis way out of this yeah
you probably put this little purpose to
go now it's fine if I could charm a way
out of the dead body or deal I could
step on a few rats with high heels no no
here I think this may have been in the
same video or at most the video right
before it where he desecrates a koi from
his own pond it's the water was
untreated so all the fish weren't moving
because they were slowly suffocating and
dying so he takes it out of the pond it
is not dead it's still breathing in a
phrase in his house yes taking care of
his face Logan Paul you think that guy
knows how to take care of a fish oh I've
just been taking
badda sells lately why why all the other
toys are fine look at how happy they are
on day we have a problem so once again
you can hear his friend being like dude
I don't know if you should be doing this
like don't put him on land man this fish
is suffocated what do I do
take him out and pound his chest you can
see how he's trying to make a bit out of
it yeah I'm it's so weird it's like an
actual fish of yours it's your fish I
know like like like okay we eat fish but
you still should have a certain level of
human sympathy for the sanctity of life
in a way of not like torturing animals
as they're dying or playing with the
corpse of an animal or be sad for a
second yeah there's some human emotion
that's normal to have and I understand
like that we're torturing or
slaughtering animals every day but still
on an individual basis you wouldn't just
go if you found a dead rat and and tase
it for joy exactly what a great rat
anecdote story oh yeah infestation a
couple years ago and a rat crawl to do
an empty trash can to put into a trash
bag and I these rats were so frequent he
was on these coasts and I know if I let
it out and come back in so I had to hit
it against the hard surface inside the
bag now I didn't take pleasure in it I
fry up I didn't like all I ask is for a
frown
I was frowning was it I wasn't rubbing
my [ __ ] I wasn't smiling it wasn't you
know giggling I was frowning and let me
look I never I didn't I didn't record in
front of a dead rigor mortis body in
Japan I feel like most people hit like
if you if you have a cockroach you have
a rent
you got a disposable right but you don't
cackle and giggle and like yeah it's a
terrible name you don't play also don't
record it for your audience after you
just did something terrible that freaked
your whole [ __ ] you ad team out that
almost imploded YouTube it does seem
like he's missing some kind of filter
the sanctity of life he's missing a
piece of his brain so that's my whole
thing on Logan Paul I think he he
wholeheartedly deserved it I think he
was testing the boundaries of how cute
he could get after this thing he wasn't
accepting any responsibility and he's
basically daring YouTube to try to stop
me because I am [ __ ] bigger than all
of you
right he's it's all part of his ego you
can't accept that he actually [ __ ] up
he's a mess I know I could still fix
this I can still make a funny joke about
it and we're cool yeah I mean he did the
same thing in the in the force we're
standing next to the bodies like what
you never seen a dead guy he's trying to
make a joke out of it I understand that
impulse but cut it out he left it in
yeah he leaves it in you know you know
it is those reactions are okay if you
have at least some sort of initial
reaction of like shock or sadness he
doesn't go ahead he has no first word he
actually jumps right into that stuff I
feel like it most people saw a dead body
they go oh holy smokes holy holy Toledo
it's a dead body
he didn't even have that he just went
running to calculate it I feel like
that's the part that's wrong with it
it's not even you know let people joke
about stuff to get over things but you
do that after you grieve or after you in
shock you don't go right into that it's
been odd if you search there's like
hidden footage of Logan like deep and
there's some crazy deep fiction up there
what have you been - put your head down
Ethan hide your face I need to check
your history all right that's enough of
Logan Paul all right I think we fully
next next
speaking of pranksters gift stirs and
gap stirs and tortures this next
prankster is is a it's a fairy tale
story of pure justice boner hard-on when
I follow this I was just fully erect
with pride and joy with the Justice of a
million Gamble's raining down on this
media this idiot of the century this
absolute [ __ ] loser
I have nothing about disdain for this
alright let me sit was that good setup
so there's this there's this English
prankster okay let me let me preface
this by saying and I was really shocked
by this there's in 2016 there was nearly
500 acid attacks in London alone yeah
when you told me that I quite leave that
I I'm gonna be fully honest I build the
wall
no but that's crazy what's the how come
is it no it's not like I didn't know
about that yeah how do I not know about
that like like let's like that's awful
500 people in one year this is when a
tear it's an act of terror they take
some kind of like corrosive acid and
they splash it in people's faces and I'm
I can't show it it's too graphic but
their skin is literally eaten off their
face and they're deformed for life and
that's the point not to kill them to
take away to take away that part of
their life of looking normal and having
a normal life it is it is a sick
barbaric it's it's it's just truly awful
this happened 500 times in London alone
in 2006 how I just learned that when I
was looking this up and I was just blown
away I mean what the [ __ ] Jesus that's
in the heart of civilization build a
wall well know that whoa build that Wow
we need a song like by that March March
build no but I don't know but but the
point I'm saying is because I'm actually
very anti wall person generally speaking
but when I read that I'm I had a large
amount of sympathy for these people
going through that they're like how
helpless can you be you're just walking
down the street some [ __ ] destroys
you and your whole family
well a lot of these were like a random
attacks to only a portion or people that
they know I read one story about but a
year and a half ago where some guy was
going to attacks like somebody who you
know diddled his kid and when he got the
wrong address you got the wrong house
and deformed the wrong
oh boy it was an act of revenge turn I
don't know if he did all the kid but he
did it was revenge it was definitely
revenge on something with his family and
he caught the wrong guy at the wrong
house got him
how do you not wait oh yes but you'll be
like oh [ __ ] my bad I was so sorry you
know what
I'm so sorry let me let me let me help
you with that let me get it paper towels
hmm well anyway that's the preface to
this prank so there's this prankster
called I mean remember his name honestly
but he was doing this really awful prank
walking around with a cup of water going
specifically to London and splashing it
in people's faces he's a young I mean
he's a young Arab man so he knew the
implication it was clearly meant to
incite the fear that they were being
asked to detect mm-hmm
because it's an act of terror right I
think that's the majority of people who
are also was it the video called the
acid attack prank I think it was called
splashing water and face break I don't
think was called acid attack it she was
pretty maybe it was let me look it up I
can find it definitely yeah and can you
find out his name was uh it's aria well
at any rate I have the clip it was
removed from YouTube it's called I think
it's called water you guys mess the
first one you guys smashed like 20,000
likes so I thought you know what
very come looking for that it's the
dumbest person you've ever heard talking
your life sounds like Ali G god this
guy's barely [ __ ] functional I'm
gonna go spy but look how he split he
splashes very violently even let's see
it it's cold it's cold as [ __ ] to like
he's wearing like a really serious
jacket in London and for faces yeah but
referring to the video if you let me
simply let's try smash 150 thousand
likes and I'll do it for you guys no
problem
last but not least is the Parkwood
anybody it's a program
oh yeah let's get the purchase of that
part but can you imagine this guy
slinging educational saying that he
didn't mention regardless this is how
those asset attacks look this is
happening when they have a crisis of
people doing this of young Arab men
throwing acid in people's faces
[Music]
excuse me goes with just listen to music
it's all tensor [ __ ] it's like oh my god
action movie
it's hardcore food throw splash water in
someone's face to run like a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you have a more pointless existence look
how dumb and pointless this is so
annoying on a cold day that's a lot of
water Oh probably below freezing
[Music]
Cory's punk rock this is what punk rock
is all about I really want to see the
raw video up this gym just breathing
heavily
[Music]
[Music]
that's just a cup of water here there's
one where he really gets a very
aggressive here this one dude that's you
know what someone needs to beat the [ __ ]
like this guy's parents need to like
punch him in the neck or something I
don't know how you discipline job but
probably not that way
that's a truly awful thing to do
what is this
your evil hearted bad spirited harmful
assault this is what YouTube pranks are
all about and it's nice to see a return
to form excuse me train Hong excuse me
can I you help me with something can you
be kind and take time out of your day to
help me
psych so hey Wei you get them you get
the gist he starts hitting on this girl
and she was boyfriend Oh
people think of the English accent is
sophisticated but I don't know what's
going on here but I've never heard of
dumber so I have a sweet obviously
throws water in her face because she's
got a boyfriend right that's the premise
and at a bare minimum he just threw
waters and reels basically she had a
boyfriend that's the least it is the
most it is is it psychologically scarred
oh if you thought you had acid you I
mean it really is that easy to throw
acid in someone's face yes yeah that's
how they so even even if I mean look at
these I don't can't talk these are fake
I was suing they seemed pretty authentic
no I think they're real this guy he's a
knucklehead he's not he's not usually
you can tell when it's fake this is the
type that's not fake he's not planning
this he comes to lunch and splashes
water in people's faces why I think the
giveaway comes later in the story that
it is real huh
I didn't know you got boyfriend in that
there boys
that's war in your face like I do
giggling and cackling like a loony so
anyway you guys get the idea so this
guy's been doing shitty pranks for a
long time and this video got picked up
by the media and started getting
reported and a lot of UK publications
because of the implications of the acid
attack they're like this guy's a piece
of [ __ ] and he's pretending and inciting
fear that he's throwing acid in people's
faces in the midst of this really this
crisis and so YouTube removes that
specific video there off YouTube and
gives him a strike okay and a lot of
people are talking about him in the UK
about what a piece of [ __ ] he is so the
genius makes a response video he's I've
been doing this for about three years
now
Abbadon pranks and just you know YouTube
in general for about three years I've
never once come across anything about
nothing about Community Guidelines
strikes
none of that care and so yesterday my
video throwing water on people's faces
when viral and the media co-op on it um
I got Daily Mail Daily Star independent
the Sun all of the media companies
literally slandering my name for
literally I prank that was meant to be
funny and a lot of grow you are [ __ ]
brain-dead like he is the embodiment is
just a prank bro it was just a finger
was meant to be funny I laugh I was
laughing like a little kid as I ran away
after through splashing water and so his
face at 30 degrees it's like how stupid
can you be
bro found it funny and all I've done the
prank was literally pour water in a cup
a subway cup and a fruit and calm
people's faces literally all I did all I
did all I did was use my car what's the
big deal
yeah like you can't preface anything
with that expect it to be okay all I did
is that it doesn't cancel out what you
do all I did was find a corpse in the in
the suicide force and click beta and
play play a quick game for a quick kiss
with it shovel people are they
wheelchairs though it was meant to be
funny I lost
I'm not riffing on the British exit but
this guy sells I don't think anyone will
take offence
I think this Celtic I think they're
ready to ship him which they found out a
joke cool
that's not appointment yes I accept that
shouldn't have done it at this moment of
time but and I accept all their comments
and stuff that's been said about me I've
been getting a lot of interviews radio
like proposals it's people hollering me
like y'all coming torture by come talk
to it and I'm thinking hold on
have you guys not seen all my videos if
you by the way
yeah and this is part that video was
part three have you guys not seen part
one and two of splashing water in
people's faces I'm a I have a track
record so basically what he's saying is
like I have never got in trouble for
these shitty pranks before why are you
all acting like as a big deal because if
this video was removed by YouTube I got
a strike why shouldn't all my other
videos
the next day YouTube erases his whole
[ __ ] channel gone every single video
his channel has been erased off the face
of YouTube we had to go to the Deep Web
to get these reuploads 700,000
subscribers like 10 million views a
month
YouTube's like you're right yeah you're
right gone it's pretty crazy completely
deserved they've been given people
passes for so long the [ __ ] is
ridiculous it's it's it's armful I just
was like oh my god after I saw this
response video I was like bro
you listen she's basically arguing for
you to be shot in shadow before guys
think this is bad have you not seen what
[Laughter]
they're trying to say like one video I
offended you guys then all my videos
were literally like anal you guys put a
plea exactly so if anybody at YouTube is
watching this please check out the rest
of our videos I think you'll find a lot
of stuff I broke the rules and every one
of my videos and nobody say them don't
look through videos have you not seen
the rest of my videos I think this might
be the dumbest person on YouTube
official award you cry when he says what
I mean Zack stick something that means
exactly what its gonna put a subway
couple my ass joke and was met never
meant to be for like these old boring
people but not only that you or old
boring people make a responsible sizable
people adults over the age of 15
also aka the people that [ __ ] running
YouTube the people that are hosting used
to be cheap has gone I listen to all
these people there not only that YouTube
has actually gone and listened to these
people and prioritized am gonna have
this guy as a future as a lawyer YouTube
didn't work out by hell because the law
school goes it I would agree but this
guy winds up in this case I'm gonna a no
you
excuse me judge you're upset about this
video the rest of my videos will
literally Anil you excuse me do you have
a girlfriend
[Laughter]
move the video and striked my channel
this is how upset he is about their
mouth I've been doing YouTube for three
years YouTube is my job
and the fact that the media want to pick
up on this situation now yesterday I was
bantering about it like cool
it's funny how I'm getting all these you
know comments and stuff because
generally I don't care about hate I
don't care about I don't care what
people's opinions I genuinely don't care
it's going to a point now where YouTube
and it's the whole situation just
playing with my business my money bro so
what that's the consequence people
aren't allowed to affect your income
you're in you're on YouTube you're
getting paid you have an employer kind
of in a way well you have to you have to
follow the rules if you don't follow the
rules you get booted that's day one you
figure that out which is not right
the video was literally of me - in a cup
of water on people's faces that sounds
bad it was just me violently throwing
water
all right I've seen enough of this
[ __ ] clowns get annulled bombings and
stabbings and pornography which has not
been deleted yet and I've seen it myself
again and you got any leaks I'm
searching for porn every day who [ __ ]
watches porn on YouTube this guy loves
this is the only guy and stabbings
embalming yeah oh just because my view
does get a couple attention um what you
want to like delete it and sigh my
channel for it no I did exactly what you
eat that's what happened the weird thing
is like he's describing exactly what
happened you know in a way where he's
like defensive but it's very reasonable
what he's saying he's a so detached from
what he's saying his reaction to it so
he's like all I did was splash water
violently in someone's face and YouTube
took the video down why did they do that
anyone else it's like yeah Salinas for
three years now I think it's not smart
enough to even like like sugarcoat it
mm-hm I've been doing videos and prank
I've been doing a harsher prank
I've been doing the way more
controversial pranks that has not been
deleted enough enough on it not even I'm
one of the there you go
it's literally someone's like great let
me find those ones and delete your whole
channel what just because it's get a lot
attention and youtubers on a bad name
for it you're gonna go ahead and listen
to all these people all these guys who
found the video was you keep saying that
that's it that's all it takes
I got a shove on his hand he's he's
talking he's just like all right all
I've done is throw water in people's
face all my other videos are way worse
alright well see you guys good night
he's animating himself yeah I could
wanna I keep wanting to stop but it's
just so entertaining I feel like it's
kind of a thrill watching the sky dig
his own grave and this moment this
moment was time what I genuinely don't
think oh this comment and oldest you
know taking down a video necessary I was
cool with being a juice box for the
Commission stuff but the fine apke get a
newspaper you're gonna have to find some
listings for a job what's this guy gonna
do I wonder what's his kid gonna be Zach
where's this guy gonna be in two years
look at Subway three cups free water
cups oh man I just love that story it's
such a wonderful it's like such a great
tale of justice porn I'm just thrilled I
love it it's great I love it so there
you have it my friends with this is
turned into kind of the prankster
episode because our next story is about
a prankster it feels like the good old
times the good old days the glory days
and there's really nothing more glorious
than this prank invasion is back finally
nice and we've all been waiting but here
I'm Chris
he's so intentionally baiting me for
another commentary channels at this
point that I feel like I can't make a
video about it anyway yeah and kind of
ruins it the the meme he's embraced the
meme too far because when she becomes
self-aware me embracing
it's like Ethan Bradberry is commenting
on every Instagram post I make he's
missing slamming on every post he's
making like a whole volume of slamming
videos which is great to watch and we
are gonna watch it today incidentally
hmm but I can't like make a three video
when you know you're self-aware about it
yeah Joey salads tweets oh I'm gonna get
back to my roots and go a dump uh abduct
some kids he does I can't do I can't
make fun of him cuz I know I know you're
you're goofing around about it so any
well I want you guys to see just a
little bit
this is kissing pranks high school
edition now you know here it's been a
long time today we're coming back strong
with kissing prank high school edition
as always let's do it as always stay
awesome who says that who says that
someone says that right yeah
stay off what grade are you I've said
that that's mine now stay awesome
everyone so here this is this is how you
know this is a real pickup game right
here listen to your senior um are you
over 18 are you over 18 what's your name
are you over 18 that's how all great
courtship courtships begin guys if you
guys got a girl for Valentine's Day this
you try that what I think I think it'll
work well it's an opening line really
one of one of the most time he'll pickup
lines of all time are you over 18
oh you over 16 mmm I love it as a second
question to white what's your name's a
photo straight to the point and to
follow and and and the older you are the
the better it plays like if you're 20
doesn't play that well if you're flex 50
are you over 18 Oh
swoon what get anal the older you are
the better it sounds when you ask how if
you're over 18 come on what swoon is
like when your heart flutters with love
it's like handled now notice these guys
in the background who are obvious plants
watch this play out I believe that oh
you wait watch this play out like this
shit's faker than I love
there were homes by the way look it up I
love that that the towers never existed
yeah the towers remember uh we're 3d
holograms that were taken down by earth
way they're played hologram it's true no
if you wanted to play a really quick
game for a kiss with me are you
yeah are you down okay Robert Zuzu go
rock paper watch the guys in the back
rock paper scissors you know it forget
the game here take a peek
pp-put the kill
as if they're so caught in the moment
that couldn't possibly acknowledge the
the mania going out going on around them
it was probably thinking like Frank
invasion is coming back with a whole we
upped the production value we got extras
we're going to we're going to high
school campuses near you by the way
after this video even with it being fake
I don't think Chris should be allowed
near schools anymore this should be a
flat out school band for Chris how old
do you think he is he's probably pushing
30
how old are you what is this oh Sh read
her open the door guest room he almost
got him what a little guy oh he's such
an angel
what a great little guy he's the
greatest I'm not worthy I'm not worthy I
always say when I see shredder us humans
are not worthy of the pure love and
appreciation that dogs give us they're
angels they're angels
I'm [ __ ] on the carpet all right that's
fine
so anyway prank invasion should be
banned from campuses but here here this
is the part where I was like man I
really can't make a video about this let
me show you the top comment on this
video in fact I'll just scroll down top
comment is of course it changed waiting
for the h3 Street reaction video lull
smiley face and he says me too
Frank invasion said me too so Adam so
it's like I don't Zack thinks that it's
a reverse psychology thing I don't know
if it's this morning it seems like it
might be I think he genuinely wants us
to react to it cuz he wants the
publicity I just I I know what's the
endgame of this what's the point of this
he had to have though this was enough to
generate attention he has like a dating
website now that he's trying to kick
traffic to so the monetization really
isn't central to his business Molly more
he says this but that's my point is he
doesn't need to make this video and he
doesn't need to make a video where his
the point of it is he [ __ ] house does
he
he needs he needs views he doesn't get
like ten million views on every video
like he used to I guess my point is what
is what does he want the audience to
think that he could [ __ ] impressionable
high school students what what is he
what is he trying to convey through the
audience yeah I mean that's the same
thing that he's always done is that if
you're bold enough and you're cute
enough and your hair looks good and you
show enough shoulders and arms right and
you have enough mascara on you can [ __ ]
any QT with the simple game of a rock
paper scissor and he's he's selling
while he's selling a fantasy first of
all for the views and second of all once
this video started getting demonetised
he built this whole how to how to get
girls based on this obviously fake BS
mm-hmm
boot camp where you pay a monthly fee so
he's he has to convince people that it's
real or otherwise he doesn't get you
know he doesn't get any of those juicy
CPAs that means cost-per-acquisition in
the marketing world all right so that's
it bring it in bring it in goddamn it
we're having a celebration it's our 50th
episode
none of us never thought we make it this
far if I'm being honest mm-hmm first of
all everyone come in here if I'm being
honest when we started this and we got
this space and we did all-out I was like
there's no way this is gonna last this
is just I felt like we had made a huge
mistake we were really close to just
shutting it all down ending our lease
scrapping all this [ __ ] and just really
dropping the whole thing but we powered
through it and I think picking up Dan de
swert our wonderful producer who took
this to the next level
he made this what it is today this
technical masterpiece we have Ian the
intern god bless him he's making waves
he's doing stuff I don't know what he's
doing but I'm sure he's helpful
he's got pizzas we've got Papa John's
holy macaroni we've got no now we said
to ourselves what better way to
celebrate than having some papa john's
pizza and some Pepsi Max and champagne
glasses there's really no better way to
celebrate okay
when I said that ela said to me she said
why don't you get another piece of
because I actually am hungry and want to
eat what do you mean
she says everyone's just being nice to
you Ethan they don't actually want Papa
John's I said oh you think that all you
think that people made Papa John's most
popular finsih Jane in America are just
trying to be nice to me you think that
cheese that butter garlic sauce is a
joke all I'm saying is I'm really hungry
I'm not in John right well so I says all
right ela your big shot let's get one
black all of mushroom Papa John and one
black all of mushroom what do we get
round table I said dealer's choice you
guys pick I don't hear anything
and now we're gonna do is taste test if
this isn't the perfect podcast material
I don't know what is listen to a
silently for people who are not watching
and listening listen to a silently chew
into the mic come on this is good stuff
so anyway guys thank you for bearing
with us and for coming along for the
ride it's been it's been a joy I love it
I love what this has become and I love
what you guys have stood here thank you
to Dan and to Sarah to entered and to
mr. hilarious out there even though it's
his first episode with us I was a big
cornerstone from day one it's all the
way we really do need a fart coming from
there so defects yeah next time we'll
have oh my god what the [ __ ] there's so
many olives on that
alright so set that up for us if you
would you can join us too for the taste
test I won't get your opinion on that
give that to you oh the frickin hater
you oh the hater that's your nickname
later
I just realized by the way very happy to
excite it in March we are gonna do our
first lot and we do it live or die right
now but we're going to do a
live audience at the improv in Hollywood
thank you very much real-life well I
don't have the link to start selling
tickets yes yet but our plan is to start
doing a live show every once a month in
LA very excited and my I've already
RSVP'd booked a huge guest my parents
are gonna do with the intro for us
they're pretty VIP I had to bend some I
had to call in some favors I had to call
in some favors for that all right so
let's let's this is really this is
really awful material but hey it's my
show
let's hear okay so this is Papa John's
are we doing it toast yeah we have to
talk what yours are the other guys
they'll know someone's gotta run the
show so Cheers Dan god bless you thanks
man
and Sarah and Ian out there and everyone
god bless you thank you guys for all
your work appreciate that was me
kissable thank you and everybody
watching everybody watching Cheers love
you do people really usually celebrate
50 we do take any reason to celebrate
more of a mean mean libration feels good
to have the math okay so Sarah Sarah
actually went on a wild goose chase to
pill cure the max apparently they're
phasing it out Sarah do you have access
to a mic well she went to uh she went to
Ralph's Vaughn's 99-cent store Costco
super as a whole ordeal my favorite part
was calling in everywhere and asking
them to look for Pepsi bags they're like
what they're like what I really made
Pepsi listen lady I have to do Crystal
Pepsi this Max is actually very nice
what is this 2017 let's see
it's been aged yeah this has been aged 3
months in good oh I can tell I can good
plastic flavors the nice figures didn't
smell bad don't don't drink it too fast
let's come on that's a $2.00 bottle all
right so before we move on let's address
the hater in the room ela let's no take
a bite of Papa John's now let's be
courteous to those listening and not
watching Papa John's feminist grab it
has a nice finish it has a nice gloss
there is it's kind of short on the
olives and mushrooms it doesn't have a
lot if you look at the round table it is
layered on yeah so on top marks on
topping is goes to round table easily
okay but I'm not saying it's better I'm
just saying it is Dan's mic not on
saying no oh oh my gosh oh my gosh
it's been cursed I don't know what's
happened then can you fix your own mic
you'll come back and join us
you ready Allah take the Papa John bite
mmm let Papa take you are you serious
after all this [ __ ] talk after all these
times dude you're the pro no come on how
about how about this can you hear me out
there guys yeah all right
take a bite I live here we go we're
doing papa I'm so going your parents
keep telling you to put on sit belt as a
kid and then they don't it's like then I
like papa all right interesting what are
you what are you in here help me it's ok
how many how many five Papa's how many
fathers do you read it out of four
that's four dads who don't love me as
for the round table who's the round
table I know Monica immediately what'd
you say I know which one immediately
ela serves your soul you know the truth
don't [ __ ] lie can I get some more
max let's all out in the count of three
say which was our favorite slice because
I don't want any one three two one
are you I cannot believe that anyone
could objectively taste those two pies
together and inside I'm a sucker for the
toppings dude but I'm not having ratio
it doesn't do anything when the pizza
itself tastes like fricking plastic I
just said it I just said it to me I just
gotta say I couldn't I couldn't say I
couldn't I couldn't not say the words
you know it's like I owe it to wait so
did you won't be honest you like to
spare my feelings tell me the truth some
comments from the peanut gallery
all right I think personally fun come on
you're being sarcastic or whatever I
think well they just I think that one
wins with the more toppings but it's not
it's like okay it's like do you have a
piece of [ __ ] with more olives like wow
oh it's got more AUB's it didn't taste
better it [ __ ] for my money Papa's in
the house I'm not finished the best
pizza in this case it's the clear Victor
I agree I don't I don't have to say it
like that
well I was really this is some good
podcasting pizza episode 50 we've peaked
everybody this is this is when everyone
stopped watching
moving on when you have some answer when
you have some data just chime in Dan but
I'm gonna move on here's a video that
really blew me the flip away this is
just this episode is all about the
classics okay we talked about the
pranksters we're getting back and I hate
saying this word but for lack of better
you know I'm not gonna say social
justice where let's say hard left hard
left shenanigans stop saying Mary watch
so this guy's thesis this guy's thesis
is that the word marijuana is racist
okay no let's let's hit listen to argue
this case
stop saying marijuana why because it's
racist ass well that is a pretty strong
statement it's racist as flip you know
your argument strongly start off your
leg with my so you stop saying your word
no it's eight anymore you're not even
arguing that it's bad but you just
saying you should say it that's really
the problem with the hard left they're
always starting every argument with that
note saying things that make me
uncomfortable and in this case he
stretches the limit of being able to
complain about someone using a word to
the outer reaches of the solar system I
just feel like you you lose like
literally like 99% of people when they
hear this stuff it sounds insane I think
it isn't saying it is but my point is I
don't know who they're trying to get who
they're appealing yeah I don't like I
felt like this if you show this video to
every person in America I literally
don't think one person would stop
segment along because that's exactly
nobody's being converted here in fact
probably hating them more I feel like
people would be more glad to say it if
they do it piss this guy off yeah let's
play the video so we know what we're
talking about people of color and their
devilish ways now the word if so here's
that kid run back there but it was used
by American prohibitionist to exploit
racism and xenophobia so by using the
n-word you're ignoring a long history of
oppression against you would talk about
that for a second the episode yeah when
you when you want to go back a little
bit so when you use the M word
you are ignoring the history of Oprah
it's like it's like it when you say
marijuana you are choosing to ignore all
the oppression of every Mexican that's
ever come to America if I don't by the
way the obvious the elephant in the room
here is you're gonna put the word
marijuana on the same level as a [ __ ]
word that has to do it like hundreds of
years of slavery like JLo and like the
Atlas fire hosing black guys down the
street chasey with dogs freaking like
google it like groups of of white
shrouded min literally hanging people
for nothing else than that because
lighting torches is just right yeah so
yeah exactly it's it with them it's just
a war of extremes it's like here's
another this is a that word it's just as
bad there's the M word knows there's no
there's no it's not there's no spectrum
is everything's as bad as the next thing
you can't have what bad thing be worse
than another bad thing everything's as
bad as everything else the M word the
first thing I thought when I watch this
was like on our limited time on this
planet Earth or the finite existence we
don't have a lot of time on this planet
you're choosing to get enraged and
bothered over this the M word there's no
implication there's there's hardly any
explanation for it you're not converting
anyone like you are literally just in
the Olympics of outrage that's what
you're competing in the Olympics of the
outrage you're going for the gold medal
our time on this planet is limited do
not start getting disturbed by the M
word for Christ's sake and and as you
pointed out Zak you have real words that
you shouldn't say like the end the
n-word is a really offensive word let's
not say that let's not dilute it and I
know this guy he probably holds that in
the highest level of offensiveness right
let's not dilute in the power of that
word by making a whole alphabet listen
am worried that's where the P word the l
word would by the way would use when you
try to make that wound we took the word
meant a lot as bad as the that word
you're you're giving it power that word
it that word has zero power right now
are you sure you're trying to make a new
horrible word you're trying to give
something power that doesn't have power
right now
nobody ever and the whole continental
United States thinks about
marijuana's as having any racial
implication at all so for this jerk up
you know what in the last thing you'll
say is if you make this word as bad as
any other like horrible swear word you
know the only people were gonna use this
are gonna be [ __ ] actual racists
we're trying to piss you off if you make
it as bad as that word right right if
you actually do it these guys were
successful in elevating this word that
the old people would use it would be
racist versus just now what everybody
says it has no question they're just
giving them more weaponry yeah I don't
think he says it's basically like saying
you know what else would offend me if
you would use that KQ please never say
this thing you didn't know ever offended
me can you please that and we say this
you've basically made it a sport to
offend us and you know what would really
offend me that you don't know about yet
cuz it's not offensive the M word you
know my biggest fear it's like the
prankster saying like this video
offended you so you should check out my
other naughty words everything that
triggers me I will weep if you say this
word I think that it really just shows
how unthought out and how unthoughtful
an unintellectual this actually is
they're trying so hard to be on like
intellectual and historical but really
this just it's really just so stupid I
mean it's really just dumb shall we
let's go on a quick history lesson shall
we uh what okay do you know anything
about history can you go back really
quick why do all these [ __ ]
publications do that thing where they
show the camera from like the site of
this guy's faces it's so weird you know
these guys explain why marijuana is
literally worse than 911 okay polar
decide camp yeah please it's show the
side of my face where I'm not looking at
the camera it's like they know they're
just in a basement in front of a green
screen that was turned into a gray grady
actually it's probably a gray wall like
we have one gray wall in our basement
that we shoot all of our videos on let's
add a second camera we don't even have a
second camera let's just shimmy this one
to the left a little bit so that it
looks like we have a higher production
pause ten feet to the left let go okay
more credibility given okay slide it
back true they all have the same silence
because there's probably be more dead
people
it's like six it's like two guys doing
all five videos a day it's probably some
frickin it's probably just some genius
producer who doesn't care at all about
social justice he's just found like a
top dollar market they love the two cam
little shimmy to the side shall we
why do you have to be so like shall we
looking down at stupid people they tell
you [ __ ] it works I just read this on
Wikipedia so let's take a history lesson
shall we yeah I was at Wikipedia for
five minutes last night at 2:00 a.m. let
me tell you [ __ ] insects a little
something [ __ ] peons soon by the
American elite since the 1840s it was
even sold over the counter as medication
to treat insomnia migraines and
rheumatism but it didn't become
controversial until the early 1900s when
millions of Mexicans migrated to the US
following the Mexican Revolution with
them they brought marijuana medical
accustomed to smoking it casually and
regular but the term was then
popularized in the 1930 look a bunch of
hooligans to me do do Wells I think I
think I'm so to agree with these guys
he's talking about wait a mo man just
bringing out you coming over smoking
weed I don't know no Anslinger believe
that marijuana influenced black and
brown people to commit murder and other
violence I'm not true cut this whole boy
down we're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] right
now that's the war so ridiculous oh it's
ridiculous
okay you know I always really do the
impression that Mexicans a black people
would smoke weed and like decapitate
white guys whatever whatever there's a
full moon but I guess I guess it's
ridiculous I'm so sorry for thinking
that it's cut to Harold and Kumar sit on
their couch wash shut up eat munchies
and fall asleep
it's nice job Elizabeth has anybody ever
heard of the
tropes of people eating and falling
asleep when they smoke weed like hey
guys did you know that you smoke weed
you get sleepy and hungry
you know decapitate white people in the
street now yes now this is funny do the
devil hordes on your hands would you say
that no I don't want this to be used we
have video 5 B decline oh man I'm so
sleepy I feel like I just smoked a joint
and a bag of munchies this pizza
you're literally [ __ ] blazed right
now I'm so blaze guys please hit that
like button if you love getting high VT
food afterwards don't call it marijuana
though oh sorry I mean the M word very
one up guys don't drink marijuana
juicing please call it the M word hey
bro can I get some M word
dude relax relax man I can already hear
just [ __ ] [ __ ] don't stop dude bro
let's let's roll it M word let's roll up
what do you how are you altering our
language you loser you out that's what
they're like we're losing the ability to
actually communicate like in 1984 those
were Jordan Pearson he's so afraid of
the far-left because they're and they're
taking away our use of words they're
trying to control how we talk in 1984
they're editing the language of removing
all the expression out and boiling it
down to as little words as possible
that's what they're trying to do in a
way we don't have any words love it's
all just gonna be l word M word well it
by the way I know it's been waived the
points of a before but a lot of every
almost every word we use today to
describe things casually like idiot
[ __ ] it's stupid and lazy those are all
medical terms at one point like episode
boron I think an idiot we're all literal
likes you bracket so like the 30s and
40s Zack you may have just said the most
offensive thing I've ever heard in my
life you [ __ ] stupid idiot lazy
all of those words you just one more on
becomes an M word then you have to my
point is it was a one right that beat
like the word M one M two um two word so
what's gonna fade to fifty years you see
it though dizzy someone's gonna watch
this podcast in the public record of
them like fifty years and look back like
we were Nazis or something the judge is
gonna slam his gavel down and say order
huh solution was to launch a vicious
propaganda campaign against mr. Wyden
here at another fight on the actual
inferior racist and so to be a little
more intense linger traveled across the
country to convince people that
marijuana was something that was
invading of the US he even pronounce the
drug ask marijuana to make it sound
Hispanic and say okay so that's he
saying it was racist to call it
marijuana because he was trying to
implicate Mexicans but nobody refers to
it as marijuana everybody calls it
marijuana that's the English word
marijuana is Spanish that guy may have
been erased his [ __ ] trying to the
you know criminalized Mexicans but
nobody says that everyone says marijuana
you buy the look in the dictionary it's
there it's an English word you can just
make like a history piece about it and
just like for your information this is
where it came from right that's
interesting
I agree but why do you have to make it
this whole thing about you can't say
this word right cuz it's [ __ ] racist
that's how we opened races [ __ ] oh yes
Father
bleep it's like bro really is it really
oh yeah I forgot to point out he goes
there's a great moment in the beginning
he goes stop saying marijuana why
because it's racist ass okay people of
color and their devilish ways now the
word is inherently racist okay wrap it
up everyone go home it's racist as [ __ ]
now the word is it inherently racist
this word is [ __ ] racist well it's not
racist it's not exactly racist well I'm
completely nullifying my own video after
15 seconds we continue our incredible he
really should be a lawyer too Oh
between him and hits Aria they're gonna
be very compelling argument you're gonna
hold court any case again the campaign
against marijuana and associated with
all inferior races and social deviants
Anslinger traveled across the country to
convince people that marijuana was
simple with successfully which made the
drug illegal at a federal level that
seems to help people with several argue
that marijuana lost its prejudiced bite
years ago but you can't ignore the
racial implications of its introduction
to the American lexicon besides nothing
has to change this whole conversation
was actually very deja vu we're still
trying to fight the negative stigma why
was he talking about yeah that I don't
understand why he throws that these
changes the 30s are you [ __ ] bonkers
dude it's legal in like five states now
people like 65% of the US was it
legalized what the [ __ ] is he talking
like twenty years ago there was actually
I paid for commercial on television
again like people would disown their
kids for smoking wait twenty years ago I
learned it from you dad
Bill Clinton said I didn't hail like
seriously wrote that he said I didn't
the hail the weed what I did in college
it was a big deal now it's like Obama's
like yeah I smoked weed yeah I did crack
I did weed that's that's races well it's
the truth brother
that's the c-word wait are you serious
head did he admit to doing crack no
that's what you know he's a new-age
president you know hey that's happen
that's how you race this phrase at these
days I've said crack once I wasn't I
didn't feel anything Obama did say he
used cocaine to be fair uh-huh that's
racist road that's race please the
c-word yeah all right let's get this
idiot off the screen see you later at
[ __ ] what's this guy's name
whatever let's not implicate myself any
further
it's quick up but up thank you for you
guys oh yeah uh split vote here Pizza
yeah we have to Papa's to round tables
in the peanut gallery I want to know
what you know yeah you you go first I'll
get my results will Suu you explain the
results there's everybody what's the
breakdown who did what everybody is uh
telling me they don't want me to reveal
that information elements Lee album out
everybody here do you see how tense it
is in this office you see I wrote the
IRS people are afraid to talk to me the
truth even my own wife there's a trash
can on file in here dude there's rights
going on there's broken windows well
that's the president because I thought
papa was a the clear winner and I was
pretty open-minded well tell you you're
careful on that one I have to agree
thank you I took a bite of the other one
it's not bad it's not bad you know and I
love myself some wells of mushrooms
don't be honest oh yeah I'll play the
[ __ ] truth I'm not going to see you
so is he a no voted in the intern
betrayal again sometimes I wonder why I
even have you here if you're gonna like
you have to back me up on these things
like I don't really care what your true
opinion is I have you here to back me up
when I need it you you're here to swing
the vote who you don't you spit her on
the floor I'm gonna be honest with you
spit all Papa John's onto the floor word
stomped on in the interval what did I do
to deserve this disrespect okay
I'm surprised but okay so it's a split
decision although ela you preferred Papa
so thank you but I don't believe her
still yeah me neither
I don't want you being so coy about it
because I gotta keep there she can't
spoil the meme dude yeah yeah I'm gonna
get when we're off the air I'm really
gonna dig in I wanna I just a personal
level wanna know all right let's keep
going don't and by the way don't use the
p-word pizza's came from Italians they
were the Italians had a rough time
called dogs they had the Italians get a
rough date people get my heart
the time that I was taking our time get
my break EULA please sorry all right so
these guys you know what I'm gonna skip
this one
the southern ones Zach these guys they
made another video called why we need
more women in comedy and frankly it is
very funny but I'm not going to touch
that landmine basic the basics of it is
it's a video of them saying we basically
we need a quota like if you look like
the the rundown is if you want to be a
woman of comedy go for it I think
nobody's gonna stop you and if you're
funny you will do well but this idea
that everything just go watch the video
you know tell me if you want to watch it
it's a landmine it's a landmine I'm not
even gonna try to make that ballerina
dance to that I'm not grateful enough to
make it out of there alive
like the lasers I'm cutting through the
bank it's not what happening don't touch
that one so that's out there if anyone's
interested bring it on back again and
the theme of just back with the old
classics
Ethan Bradbury is back slamming again
and I mean there's definitely something
to talk about here it's so funny that
like for a whole year we were trying to
get their attention and they would
completely ignore us they act like we're
crazy even two years yeah and then now
when demand is kind of like no one cares
they're trying to bring him back he's
making even Brad Barrow singer Lee he's
got like a whole this is volume to
slamming but he's got like five slamming
videos now and he call us at every one
of Ella's and mine Instagram saying
slamming is everything is slamming
it's like Ethan you missed the train bro
well anyway let's watch it here because
I can't really make h3 tweet about it
it's still I mean it's still a journey
through to man
look like they really stepped other
production value they've got all these
artistic shots what do you what are the
chances they actually cleaned that cup
up do you think I was thinking about
that probably zero right bro I love this
Omar go clean up can you fly through CGI
yo he has the intro of like a serious
animation production house and what if
I'm here's like a al kufan Bradbury
productions no no production music
serious - yeah this is like this is a
real genuine expression this is then a
wreck this cut
you having a good day y'all enjoying for
the right offenses users y'all have a
nice little brunch nice they're like oh
man this guy he's away from his care
[Music]
by the way boob with their boob coming
out warning [ __ ] yeah dude look at that
boob coming out
we need a Joey salads cream yeah still
we have do we yeah we're stuck where's
that that was real or oh man I wish that
I reacted as [ __ ] that way like how cool
would your life be would someone bother
you you [ __ ] I would have such sass free
in right now and you would hear some
sass from me if that was me damn yeah
you know what that was um but you get
the idea yet II gotta yes there's a
really great one can I try yeah he takes
this poor son of a [ __ ] gonna watch
this can I try a few madness with him
here just imagine being this poor guy at
the donut yeah
nah just ridin can I try
like you know like well you're not
giving me any option he's like you know
what it's not worth dying over this
today this guy this guy's check his belt
to me out there's no there's no lump
sticking out he's like you know what
this guy is a Looney tune and I don't
want to anvil on my head that's great
really elevating the heart he say weak
urge this you oh yeah two years ago did
we encourage this donuts known as a
direct consequence of us you bad you
make it to that age and Kitty bullied
first types it's really 12 No also can
you say B word on man there's a lot of
Ebola it's triggering your right now
yeah you word toilet duty bead I got
beat at school day I got anal didn't
school today mom don't say pee don't say
Boyd honey say annulled
this guy's like can somebody call the
cops yeah she's posted with this poor
ladies it's just the intro and the music
and everything is just really bizarre
and then the music so it's really
serious it's very serious it's almost
like a psychotic confession yeah this is
who I am
Bradbury bill and Brad Berry Farms so
anyway that's one there's another one
this like I told you there's like he's
got volumes of this [ __ ] you just walks
front and screaming slamming today
pretty much easy job
this one's a journey through madness in
love with that intro
hello everyone welcome back I'm Ethan
Bradberry if you guys are brand new I
welcome you guys on ball with all this
slime base where some of the most
powerful lies shakable people out there
you guys are returning I welcome you
guys like thank you
that was beautiful I need them so I felt
wonderful so they're Miami you know
there's so he has a one of these guys
here cuz I'm sick of you don't have also
got potato soup oh my god so that's a
hard sell lie I'm wondering and his mind
he's like I'm not I know you're being a
douche and I and I want to be completely
unfazed I think I think he does that
like crazy by the way yeah I saw this
someone asking where did mo go I'm 100
and it's not the intro says Ethan
Bradberry why they split yeah Wow
did they have a falling-out yeah one
Bradbury one got slammed too hard got
eight old boy that's a wrong da game
right and now he's got this like dollar
store mo Bradbury look who's this guy
well it's wrong nobody cares about you
[Music]
not make the experience just had right
now he really really likes I'm told out
all good I'm new here you know so anyway
so now here he is back at his Graham in
his grandma's living room but the couch
is covered in plastic don't know Kelly
and Ryan Seacrest they invited me to
this show because of how strong we
really are and they really so in his
story Kelly Clarkson and Ryan Seacrest
invite him to their show let's see if
that's true
so they've invited me onto this show and
you know they wanted me to slam for them
Ryan Seacrest inviting Ethan Bradberry
on the slam
[Music]
[Applause]
being escorted off by security I was
invited on they really know Irish
powerful in slamming I love a whole
month and they wreck their now so that's
a that's a journey through Bradbury
farms there's some fresh ones still to
pick but honestly winter is coming and I
think these Bradbury's about to wither
and die off with the with the harsh
winter cold that's coming I'm hoping
that comes spring we'll have a fresh
harvest with some new berries but I
think these slam berries are just about
picked that a good man was that a good
honestly we've got some more other stuff
to talk about but I think we're good we
got the Elan a space thing I guess we
should touch on that
let's close it up with Elan we were
getting pretty heated about that Zac
when we're talking about so Elon Musk
most of you probably heard the news that
SpaceX has basically revolutionized
space travel by first of all what they
did is they invented a rocket that can
not only launch in an outer space with
cargo but it can land itself and save
the actual rocket for reuse NASA for
example they used to launch it into
space and the rocket would come crashing
down to earth and was just complete
garbage it will cost them like eighty
million dollars per launch and what's
what SpaceX has done is literally cut
the cost in half it cost them forty
million dollars to launch and the cargo
capacity has doubled and what they've
done recently has proved the concept I
hello pop a jumper up there
what's the pepsi max burp so so Elon
being the showman that he is he's got
the song he's got the dance he's a he's
a god he took his original roadster
which was the first generation of Tesla
cars which is extremely heavy car I'm
put it in this rocket with a a rocket
man in a spacesuit in the driver's seat
and webcams and shot it in to space
one of the most spectacular and coolest
things I've ever seen in my lifetime
that was obviously just a stunt it was a
PR it was a marketing move the real
intention was to proved the concept of
this new rocket they had that could
launch twice as much cargo and land
itself and cost half as much done by a
private company NASA has been left in
the smoke and NASA is now paying SpaceX
to bring their cargo to the
International Space Station so first of
all before we get into that controversy
let me just show you some pictures
because they are absolutely breathtaking
I mean this is this for example is a
real picture this is a real picture yeah
it's crazy this is unbelievable this is
the coolest [ __ ] ever and it was also
playing on the radio spaceman by David
Bowie I love that like the guy has got
it all he's got it all he is a marketing
genius and and frankly look at this
photo it's crazy that um two million
people were watching this live it was
one of the most watched live streams
ever I think it had like 2.1 million
concurrent viewers unbelievable look at
this photo this is a real photograph
this is a real photograph look at that
flat earth right there if you're willing
to buy the lies of a private company
like SpaceX then I don't have a help for
you sheep this is a real photograph that
that just I don't know blows my mind
personally there's so many excellent
photographs from the livestream look at
this one bro you [ __ ] kidding me the
reflection of the earth on the hood of
the Roadster mm-hmm so essentially most
everyone is like this is great this is
super cool I feel like this is an in a
weird way on a real big achievement for
Humanity and for space exploration and
space industry well of course anything
great and cool doesn't come without the
contrarians
the haters we will just want to complain
and I'd say you can't say marijuana you
have to say the n-word now I have a
feeling it's the same exact people so
here's the whiners and the contrarians
first let's start with what was it salon
yeah now there's actually a great little
rabbit hole here on their website you
click you go to salon and they say you
have adblock and I mean that's fair
enough they don't want you to use
adblock but then this is kind of weirded
me out they says we would like to use
your computing power you can support
salon.com by allowing them and use your
processor for calculations calculations
are clearly executed in your browser
installing this is a [ __ ] virus don't
click it we stole a Bitcoin mining virus
on your computer because you have
adblock no this is a scam no what you
can't so I just spoil it don't click
that look I don't I don't condone using
adblock we have to do it for the sake of
the show whatever I I have it whitelist
on YouTube but I found that interesting
but here's one that we can actually read
from The Guardian and it is called why
Elon Musk space launch is utterly
depressing I am utterly depression I am
I am so joyless honestly a lot must
reconsider I am utterly and and
absolutely devastated by this launch
it's frankly ruined my entire year I
wish you luck must put this [ __ ]
right over the car instead of the little
boxes that yeah by the way the title of
the other salon one that wants to
install Bitcoin mining virus on my
computer was why Elon Musk's space
launch was a slap in the face to real
science as if you're someone to quantify
what real science means it's not real
science to [ __ ] invent a new rocket
that can land itself and launch other
parts that's not real science real
science is writing a complaining article
on the internet posting real science is
installing how bloatware to my bitcoins
that's real science real science so hard
to impress what can you say I'm a
journalist I know what's real sighs the
doodle is for salade by the way yeah
what do you do for a living right yeah I
read Wikipedia for a living
I'm like Elon Musk
the horsy that's a good appetite really
effectual labor reporting the news or
just say I don't like Elon Musk cuz he
runs the [ __ ] new kind of rocket into
space well what a prick because he
didn't we'll get it to why they so
anyway this one's called
he this guy's utterly depressed you a
musk is right silly and fun things are
important but some of them are
indefensible waste of resources they are
beyond silly fun so I so here's the open
factories criticism wouldn't make sense
if you just did it no purpose to throw
his car in there yeah but no but even
then it's his own money you can [ __ ] it
to everyone so you can launch a rocket
and then you can at least I kind of yes
you know criticize it but the car was
like the secondary well it was a PRT my
point is if he would this guy what look
this guy's how much is he worth billions
of dollars obviously like five billion
the fact that he's even investing in
space at all at all I think it's his
money he only did feel at square he
could literally he could invent a giant
toilet it's warm around the side of it I
don't care I don't care what he does
when Tony does that you know when you're
billionaire I can't wait to see what
giant toilet I I don't know I think it's
a pretty fair thing to say your your
point is like even higher level than
what we need is a bare minimum bare
minimum so you have that defense right
second of all he's testing the concept
he had to put something there
this person says one on Wednesday two
things happen in Syria eighty people
were killed by the government airstrikes
meanwhile in Florida
Elon Musk fired a sports car into space
gets one guess which story has dominated
mainstream media news sites of course is
dead it's way more remarkable I'm sorry
to say but people diets tree a lot
there's a lot of saturation of stories
like that and the cars only ever been
launched into space one time as a pretty
incredible feat why should he not have
any more airtime like I'm not trying to
trivialize the deaths of people in Syria
but what just because one dudes starving
it like I had a friend he says oh
there's a there's a famine in Uganda and
he's launching cars into space just
because some dude in Uganda doesn't have
a sandwich doesn't mean that one must
can't simultaneously launch a advance
space exploration sorry I'm solid in
advance
the human race and also that feed
everybody is that good luck for you I'm
sorry I'm right like they're not
mutually exclusive like Elon Musk it
doesn't need to worry about feeding
people and you got it before he launches
a car into space that's not how like
collective minds work also on a bear
level this guy's made PayPal he [ __ ]
it in a Tesla IV the Hyperloop SpaceX
this guy's would was to accomplish human
beings I know he gets a lot of you know
a padding on the back on lines but he
deserves I think he gets a lot of [ __ ]
to share Ian's my point is if you make
if you're responsible for that many
amazing things I just it what the [ __ ]
does that have to do with people getting
airstrike in Syria like they're not
related I like I like are we not
supposed to celebrate anything by those
persons like Elon Musk had an incredible
achievement one once in a Latin we've
never seen anything like it before
the most exciting thing since people
landed and walked on the moon are we not
allowed to celebrate anything
simultaneously 80 people died in Syria
let's just [ __ ] be sad and depressed
all the time let's not celebrate
everything when when there's one tragedy
anywhere on the planet
we need to obsess with that and never
have any joy in our lives and by the way
how many how many people were dying on
earth when the mood lately happened in
1960 well you know what that was just a
trip like an N and the moon walking was
a slap in the face to real science
everywhere Zack and we please the M word
you know moon is is offensive to the to
the Chinese who built the railroad who
made moving the parts on the rock on the
shuttle possible the M word don't true I
feel you could trace the roots back of
anything enough to like oppression it's
like yeah dude for the 1920s everything
was built by just throwing minorities
suffering at [ __ ] don't say trained
Chinese built the tracks back then it's
very racist it's basically the same
thing which what's more remarkable the
biggest thing to happen in space
exploration is like the [ __ ] what 90s
or people be airstrike to Syria just
been happy for the last 10 years I don't
so once it just it's not a point and
another point that that I saw was like
he could have launched a bunch of little
satellites and
until orbit he could have asked NASA and
they would have given a bunch of little
satellites to monitor whether it's like
cool that could have done one thing but
he could have also had like the greatest
media PR stunt of all fricking time
because people are looking at pictures
of space they're interested in space
exploration it's it's everybody's
talking about SpaceX it's brilliant so
now Jeff Bezos from Amazon also has a
space company Blue Origin
I think Elon Musk started this
absolutely he wants the space race it
he's giddy I think it's great I think
it's space race is exactly woody but
this idea that he's that Elon Musk is
obligated to solve all of the world's
problems at once or is that all to solve
it even when all is so [ __ ] naive and
it's just self contrary because Elon
Musk would have never got to the point
where he is if he cared more about feet
giving people in Uganda sandwiches like
he is an inventor he's a technologist
he's a he's a he's an innovator this is
what he does this is guy stuff to help
too
it's not like maybe I don't know but
he's not obligated to I let's say he's
not ugly it is his own money he got rich
off his own genius he didn't hurt
anything to my knowledge he seems like a
smart guy you mean he's a self-made
billionaire
no he's didn't inherit anything he came
here was an immigrant from South Africa
right and he began the Hyperloop PayPal
all these are the things that are
happening and you're pissed off cuz he
didn't launch a bunch of little [ __ ]
tiny satellites in space shut up
personally I take the Roadster I'll take
the humans if you have two parallel
universes where one he shoots the little
satellites and one he shoots the roaster
maybe those little satellites collect
some data for NASA and [ __ ] and we get
some interesting data and that's cool
and and it probably doesn't amount to
much more than that right and then maybe
the Roadster leads to Jeff Bezos and
another billionaire or and other
governments entering a new space race to
try to cut down on the cost because
SpaceX now has a monopoly on sending
cargo to space because it's so much
cheaper and all the governments in all
the world are paying SpaceX so China is
also done or Jeff Bezos is like hey I
want to compete with this space and they
start building [ __ ] and it gets cheaper
and all of a sudden you've got all this
[ __ ] infrastructure in space you've
got all this stuff invested in space and
then let's say in 50 years a meteorite
comes plunging towards the earth and all
of a sudden because of his [ __ ]
roadster in space we've got all this
[ __ ] and outer space from this highly
developed business
and we're able to divert its trajectory
because of all the space stations and
[ __ ] we have in space and and and and
and it literally avoids the extinction
of humanity because of the space race
Elon started and meanwhile all these
[ __ ] satellites floating around are
floating around the rubble of a
destroyed ruined planet earth because
you're so sighted and pathetically
enraged that you dared to question the
will of Elon Musk you pathetic fool you
so goddamn pathetic right now I can't
wait for it was a space prime did you
sit down like Papa John's own basics
basic rocket yeah basic your rocket ass
your space you papa John here
alright I'm fired up read a tad more the
article before we drop this [ __ ] okay
because there's some real beauties in
there there's some real gems the much
appreciated launch much-anticipated
launch from of Musk's a falcon heavy
rocket the most powerful ever launched
by private company ever launched ever
yet ding dong how about [ __ ] who fixed
that record a little bit went off
without a hitch must successfully send
his cherry red Tesla roaster hurtling
towards Mars musk expects the rocket and
car to orbit the Sun for hundreds of
millions years though some have
speculated that will disintegrate within
a year as if that matters like you fool
if you expected to live for eternity but
it will actually disintegrate in a year
the event attracted phenomenal publicity
at one point two point three million
viewers were watching the events
livestream making it a masterstroke of
advertising for Tesla meanwhile on Syria
were hundreds of thousands refugees may
be forced to return to unsafe homes amid
global anti refugees blacklash an
anti-government activist said
despondently that he no longer sure why
he bothers to videotape the effects of
bombing since nobody ever pays attention
I how is that Elon some problem yeah
what does that have to do
hey stop having you space programs so we
can look at what I mean what the hell
does this writer want it's not even
related the UN Human Rights coordinator
for Syria pondered what level of
violence it would take to make the world
care saying officials were running out
of words to describe the crisis sorry
I don't see how that relates to you on
musk I don't have a solution for you
world is tough place man
geopolitics is in my game I don't know
maybe you need to hire a Martin better
marketing maybe you need to launch a
[ __ ] rocket into space you say the
Syrian refugees need better PR hey I
don't know what to say I don't answer
for you you're not gonna be Elon Musk
watching a roaster into space if that's
what you think do you think that's a
tragedy that you saw that's like the
equality of outcome like you were saying
like all there should be more female
comedian comedians despite how funny
they are we just deserve it the quality
of outcome they're like hey Assyrians
are dying
why does not not get more attention than
a literal car roat's are being launched
into outer space
sorry one's way more [ __ ] interesting
it's true oh well you can't you can't
force people to be interested in
something it by the way being interested
in caring about something or two
different things you could be you could
care about the Syrian refugee thing but
this we thank you for crap I didn't mean
like hey I don't care I'm just saying
once way more [ __ ] sensational yeah
also also how many people want to see
Syrians get [ __ ] involved yeah it's
helping suppressing you can't go about
your life you can read about it you can
you can you could be interested in it
whatever so yeah what does it have to
have fun but again the biggest things
are not related they're [ __ ] on two
completely yeah after that related it's
completely unrelated I mean Trump could
have [ __ ] you know his hair blew in
the wind going up onto the horse one
that gets more coverage than the Syrian
it's getting bombed but sorry man yeah
that's what happens it's just a stupid
hardcore but they publish it the
Guardians a huge paper yeah but this by
the way is also this this is this
sentiment was was pretty ripe I saw a
couple places
yes it's very ripe and and it was echoed
by a good friend of mine who's a
reasonable guy yeah you know it's very
cool to be contrarian and hey ela must
just because he's a billionaire who does
crazy things and has a little fun with
his life we don't have enough time on
this planet you how about both how about
how about you watch the Syrians and you
feel bad
and you also celebrate the rocket launch
probably a lot of people saw both not
only to have fun advancing humankind
with amazing scientific feat so you have
to frown while you're doing across your
arms ago you know this will gonna watch
your car to space you can't be happy
about it you can't be [ __ ] silly with
uh alright that's yeah so that's it
that's all I got guys I got a lot more
here but I think I'll save it I'm
thinking and hoping if you guys enjoy
this we'll do another one on Tuesday and
hopefully we'll make it a regular thing
if you guys are into it say my regular
I'm not gonna commit to every Tuesday
cuz come on I get you do but stay tuned
we're gonna be having tickets on sale
soon there's only like 180 and not very
it's a we're just a small we're testing
it so it's a small venue but in the
future I think when we work out all the
kinks we want to sell go to a bigger
venue so we can house more people Gary
it's gonna be yes in real life
everyone's gonna be like you're fatter
and shorter than much fatter and shorter
than I thought you were that's actually
the opposite of what people always tell
you I know they oh I don't wanna be too
self-congratulatory we've all always
think that anything is better than he
really is people actually always say I
think you're taller and skinnier which
is nice but also it's kind of just kind
of like why do you think I'm so short
and pudgy okay but you're always making
yourself look yes with the Fupa stuff
well I'm not skinny that's for sure guys
thank you so much for watching thank you
to mr. hilarious I don't know if that's
working trying to think of a nickname
for Zach I don't think mr. hilarious
worth I'm still man this was psychic you
know what I have an idea tweet tweet at
us the podcast to myself everybody what
do you think what a glib should be and
please be really cruel and violent I
mean I really want to have a I want you
to ruin my day
we're in the receipt sack yeah that's
for you know what guys
tweet it be and also tweet a look at
Paul right now then second points a joke
dude don't do that whatever you do guys
I was just joshing around
yanking your leg um no but seriously
thank you the great and wonderful and
very hilarious sack okay second couples
I love them very much and thank you all
you guys for sticking around for 50
episodes so cool thank you to Dan thank
you to Sarah Thank You Diann
thank you to you long thank you and
thank you to our sponsor
Teddy fresh calm guys head on over to a
fresh are non collection just dropped
today
use the code h3 a check out for free
shipping and don't tell anybody you can
tell your friends if we find out you
told anyone we're canceling the coupon
so we will be back on Thursday with
rhett and Link so please join us then
and until then have a great week go out
there and be the best possible person
you can be
or your money back thanks for watching
everybody
have a great day Tata daddy else